one of the ways one of the healthy ways
that we can respond to fear is to affirm
the thing that we desire
affirm the thing that we are trying to
be if we need courage
affirm that if you want to trust affirm
that if you need clarity
affirm that why don't we try that why
don't we try an
affirmation that will support and assist
you
in standing courageously and trusting
that no matter what happens you will not
lose
work with me try this
i am standing for myself within myself
now take a breath
i am standing for a new vision
now take a breath i am
standing for my divine purpose
now take a breath
i am standing for my highest and
greatest good
now take a breath
[Music]
let's do that again
[Music]
i am standing for myself
within myself now take a breath
when we think we are unworthy it means
that
for some reason we believe that we have
to prove
we have a right to our space
on the planet in life as we are
being who we are and that means that we
will do
all manner of wonderfulness
to prove we deserve to be here and
usually
some of the common things are we over
commit
over give we overdo we we
over excuse we overcompensate
and we stay in difficult desperate
hurtful harmful situations
much longer than it is wise or
productive to do so
worth what it is that you
expect from the world in response
to who you are it's very different
from value self-value means
how you hold yourself within yourself
and what you expect
as a result now in order to get to the
world
if you're not holding yourself within
yourself as worthy
then what you expect from the world is
surely gonna
hurt you so here's an assignment for you
for the next 40 days every morning
you are to write 40 statements of
i am i am love i am beauty
i am peace i am joy i am power i am
worth
i am value i am truth i am light i
am wealth health whatever it is i am
and write it as a noun not as a verb
not i am loving or i am lovable i am
love
i am power every day for 40 days if you
miss a day go back and do it again
i am it will restore your work no matter
what mask or what face you wear
in the world your real self knows the
truth
and there was a time in my life when i
acted like i knew a truth
that i didn't know and the truth i
didn't know
was the depth of my value and my worth
you see i had already been an author
that had sold
over 6 million books 14 different titles
i had already been on my own television
show i had traveled around
the world i had spoken to hundreds of
thousands of people
and still i did not know or
value my own worth so in a very big
opportunity to go
forward and to be on what was once
called the oprah winfrey show
yes and i went on the oprah winfrey show
and miss winfrey
asked me back again and again and again
and eventually i became part of her
change your life
faculty and it was all good i had
written 13 books
i had traveled all over the country i
had done her show repeatedly
but i didn't know my own sense
of worth so what happened i tried to
live in a place that i didn't believe
was true for me
and eventually i crashed and burned
crashed and burned by leaving
the oprah winfrey show and going on to
another network
and doing another show that didn't even
survive a season
all because i didn't know my
worth now it would have looked like all
sorts of external circumstances oh there
was a miscommunication between me and
miss winfrey
and the other network was offering me a
lot of money and why shouldn't i take a
big business deal
no it was about me not
knowing my own worth me not being able
to stand
in the miracle of being on the oprah
winfrey show
repeatedly among honored teachers
without having to work
hard for it because that was what
i had been taught the matter with me was
that i didn't know how to receive a gift
a blessing without working hard for it
so when things came to me easily i blew
them up
it's self-sabotage or procrastination or
forgetting
or whatever it is that opportunity went
away
because i didn't know my work that's the
kind of truth
we have to tell each other we have to be
aware of it we have to acknowledge it
and we have to accept it and then
we have to look at what makes me live
less than
my truth is it because it's not safe for
me to tell the truth
so many of us live a life as children
where we tell the truth
the big people get mad at us is it
because we don't feel supported
and being the great grand glorious wise
beautiful creative people that we are
or is it that we just never felt loved
enough to know that we matter
never ask anybody permission
to do what you need to do in your life
and
never expect anybody to know more about
your life than you do that's your life
if you can't live it how in the world
you think somebody else is going to be
able to live your life for you
i want you to be able to see and
feel and experience the shift in your
consciousness
when you start living the truth of who
you are
when you begin to acknowledge
what's the matter with you and what
matters to you
and that when you have a toolbox of
principles
of skills of information that you can
put to use
in your relationships in your work life
building and healing your mental life
your emotional life your spiritual life
and your physical life you gotta
understand
who you are understand what makes you go
tick
what makes you go talk and what makes
you go boom there's some things that
would tick-tock and boom me all at the
same time i had to separate them out
because as you get older you just can't
handle that much stress
there are probably three things today
that will make me
angry angry
one is abusive children when i see it
when i hear it i go totally brooklyn and
i'll roll up on any god
other thing that makes me angry but it
won't move me to do anything
is woman on woman violence and i think
the other thing that
really makes me angry angry
is people who can help and don't i won't
roll up on you like i will if you mess
with children
and i won't you know scour at you like i
will if you're women fighting women
but if you can help and you don't it
hurts my heart and then it just takes me
into a deep place of prayer
i know that about myself but i also know
what's going to make me laugh
there's some things that people think
are fun that i just don't think about so
i remember when i went skiing and all my
girlfriends said
oh we gotta go on this ski trip it's
gonna be so much fun well first of all i
don't do cold well
any kind at all only thing coal i like
is ice cream
so but of course it's an opportunity to
shop
so i went out and bought all new ski
stuff
you know matching pants and matching
black jacket and the hat and the gloves
and
shopping is fun for me doesn't matter
what the occasion
and then i got on the thing
people think this is fun i think it not
like i got on the thing that takes you
to the top of the mountain
the lift well i didn't know there was a
beginning in advance and an
expert
so you know we all went up and because
we were being more cute than we were
being cautious
we just got on the first one which was
like the advanced one
and so when we got to the top of the
hill it's like well damn what you do now
because the thing the lift it don't go
down
it only goes up nobody bothered to
mention that
so now we've got to ski down the
expert the slope
these are black people from brooklyn
you don't even know where to buy skis
okay
and then the lie is as a black woman
woman you can't ask for no help
but i needed jesus and all the disciples
none of us knew how to skate all right
someone came along to help us because
they could
and they told us to get in the position
and to lean
but since we were holding on to each
other the first one the slide just
dragged together
well i don't know how far down the hill
i got before
i ended up very unceremoniously around
the tree
oh wait a minute see that's exactly what
happened
you see how that happened i said you
know what this is not for black people
you got to know these things and and
look at them and have fun with yourself
what is it that makes you smile what is
it that brings you joy
what is it that pisses you off what is
it that frightens you what is it that
makes the pee run down your legs
what's that that's the real fun thing
yeah because if there's not something in
your life
that pushes you to the point
where the p is running down your leg
then you ain't living big enough
freedom means offering
your life moment by moment
to move you forward standing in your
inner authority to determine
what you are going to choose moment by
moment
that's freedom and if you keep telling
the story
about what happened what didn't happen
what they did
how they did it you're gonna be enslaved
to the past hear me
you know i love you give up the story in
2021
i don't care what it is it's not going
to work for you
and here's how you're going to give up
the story
step one to freedom ready step one to
freedom
look up
look up
get out of your humanness and step into
your divinity
look up and it doesn't matter
what you're looking up to whatever that
is for you
if that's god if that's jesus if that's
the angels the ancestors
buddha krishna allah look up
in 2021 you got to look up
you might just want to walk around like
this
if you want to experience freedom this
year you've got
to look up you can't look because that
it's so unstable and so uncertain that
something could be going on one moment
it's not going to be going on the next
moment you could have something in one
moment
and not have it connect so you have to
look up and know that your good is
coming from above
can you hear me does that make sense
look up how do i look up mission
what do you mean look up well
write your visions down because you get
to choose what you want your life to
look like
but you've got to write it down you've
got to get it out of your mind
why because there's ants in your mind
we've talked about that last year
you got ants not in your pants but in
your mind
another negative thought so when you
have your good visionary thoughts up
there
the ants are going to crawl all over
them write it down put in your journal
put it on the index card
put it on the refrigerator i don't care
where it is and once you write it down
look up i'm writing this down
another way how do i look up mission how
do i look up
in your prayer look up in your prayer
your prayer
is a step up it's a look up if you pray
so you got your journaling or your
writing of your vision
of your desires write it down
and look up pray about it look up
these are choices it's a choice to pray
it's a choice to journal it's a choice
to write stuff down
write it down look up pray look up
that's the first step towards freedom as
opposed to looking around and looking
back and looking over
and looking under look up okay
look up here's your second step let go
let go once you write it down
and once you know and we're going to
talk about because you can't not do
anything but we're going to talk about
how to do what you need to do
to move yourself forward so that you can
remove stay free
but once you write it down once you pray
about it
you're looking up now you let go that
means that you don't obsess
that means that you don't worry
i had a uh somebody tell me the other
day to take any other class that i'm
doing i don't know how many of y'all are
in the class with me
but this woman said she prayed about her
son
she did her work she hadn't seen him in
so long and the day after she finished
her prayer or whatever she was doing she
heard from it
okay look up let go
so that you don't have to be burdened
with the how
you have to focus on the what
if you have a what the universe of life
will provide you with a
how so you can remain free
you can remain free worry
will enslave you control will enslave
you
so if you want to be free if you want to
experience
freedom these are things you must choose
to let go of
i refuse to worry i've discovered
that when we stay in a certain state of
mind or way of being
for it could be 24 hours we attract
energy yeah we're all energy everything
is energy
and as we grow and heal and do our
spiritual work
we can clean our minds we can clean our
hearts
but we've also got to clean our energy
yeah so it was really
a brain child of my daughter who passed
away
from colon cancer she created this line
of body products called masterpiece
how do we master peace p-e-a-c i love
that
and the way we do that is to make sure
our minds our hearts our bodies
and our energy is clear so what i was
able to do
was to recreate the line of masterpiece
products
and right now we we have a body wash
that is made
i hand make right it's amazing with
essential oils
with herbs using a base of african black
soap
which is known for its skin healing
healing properties uh because i want
people
to clear their energy sometimes if you
clear your energy
it makes the internal work easier to do
we have to clean up our minds
by having a clear vision about what we
want to do
it is amazing to me to me
and i'm i'm just uh you know i'm coming
out the projects in brooklyn
but it's amazing to me the number of
people that live
every day without a vision just
walking around blindly waiting to see
what's going to happen
that would make me crazy as all day long
i was gonna say a bad word but i it's
children in the room so i cleaned that
up i cleaned up my mouth
and it's 2013.
[Laughter]
a vision
the great philosopher nietzsche said if
you have a strong enough what
the how will be provided
and the vision is your what what
are you doing i remember my grandmother
used to say that to me i was telling
somebody earlier
my people are from right here in
smithville virginia
right in smithfield i was in smithfield
out of brooklyn
every summer as soon as the school door
closed i was in the car
on the way down to smithfield and half
of my family worked in the guatley meat
factory maybe that's why i don't eat
ham to the day i had a pet pig
of my very own okay i've had enough pork
to last me
four lifetimes okay but
my grandmother used to say to me what
are you doing
what are you doing and you know those
kids oh nothing
but it's amazing when we look at adults
today
how many of us don't know what we're
doing
with our gifts with our skills with our
time with our talents
with our lives we gotta have a vision
and that begins in the mind i'm not
talking about a to
do list i'm talking about being able to
look into your life and see how you want
it to be
don't worry about the how get the what
what does your life represent we got to
get it clean
in 2014 and encourage our family members
and our partners and our spouses
my partner is a journalist he's a
journalist or he's really into details
sometimes i just don't even want to tell
him what i see because then he gonna
have a list of 55 things that have to go
but it gets done it happens
it unfolds it occurs
because a vision will pull you
forward one of the things i believe that
girls inc
has is a vision for the young children
a vision to see them stronger and more
productive
to see them moving ahead clean up your
mind
get a vision and it'll pull you
forward don't worry about the how god
never gives you a vision
without the provision if you do the work
of
seeing it how to get to it will be
provided to you that is
if you're in alignment if you want some
amazing affirmations with
les brown check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there there are losers
and there are people who have not
discovered how to win
and all they need is some coaching all
they need is some
help and assistance